Alright guys, so this is going to be the last example for the Holy Grail strategy, and this is going to be a unique strategy, sorry, example, alright? Instead of going from external liquidity to internal, we're going to go from internal to external, and I thought that it would be best to show you one example as well, although I don't use this method, but it can work for you as well. I mean, it does work but I don't like it for some reason, I don't know what's the reason, but yeah. So, for this method, for this thing to be like rate accurate, you have to look at the autoflow.
we bearish so you want to look at the bearish fairly gaps right so over here
but we have on the for our timeframe so on for this example we're gonna go
from four hour to five or fifteen minutes to one minute okay so this is the
fairly gap right and this is practically our take profit level right it could
also be this here because that is the external activity here so now let's go to
the 15 minute timeframe and look for a shift in the market structure and that
happens right there with this structure break right so now what we're looking
for so you could have simply taken your entry from this fair value gap but as
you can see that price came here there was not enough range for us to be going
to the one minute timeframe and look for consolidation here right so what we can
you. As firstly, you could have used the strategy by itself. You know, taking the entry
using two time frames. But now that we have gone way below, we can look for continuation
purges, right? So over here, but you can see as we had this purge here. So let's go
and study what happened here. Because I want to be clear, clear with you guys. There
is no consolidation here do you see the consolidation I do not look at this this is the starting
point right we're going up lower lower high lower high lower high sorry high high high high high
high high high high this is like no consolidation here so we do not take the trade here let's go to
the 15 minute time from once again I'm showing you the different variations of each so as you
because it's not gonna be like you know like a birter like it's you will not get the same
price section like before okay it's gonna be different every time but you have to scout out these setups so
over here we also have a continuation perch but look at this move guys this is not a perch this is a breakout
okay and even if we like let's say have this level right because this is the move but there's no
consolidation here let's go here once again there's no consolidation here so we are still not
interested in taking that trade. So let's go to the 15 minutes once again and now at 1045 right we
have a purge. Now this is the move that took out this so now we have to scout out for consolidation
here and right away what do you see we have this beautiful consolidation right there.
Dear this is what I'm trying to teach here. You have to look for these things okay
Okay, consolidation phase here,
accumulation phase one, accumulation phase two,
three and even four here.
So now we take out this liquidity, right?
We have a shift in the market structure.
We're gonna take our entry from the breaker block
because our stop's gonna be going,
they're like anyways, right?
That's gonna be our entry, stop right above the highs,
Right there and looking to target these levels.
Also look at this thing.
We have a fake bullish auto flow.
So when you have this, every single fairytale gap is respected.
Fairytale gap respected.
Fairytale gap as well.
That is respected.
And this one is respected as well.
But then this is all build up of liquidity, right?
So now let's see how this plays out.
Beautiful.
Right?
Beautiful delivery right now if you waited for let's say okay here's why did I take my entry from this breaker block
Right because we have a fairly gap inside this breaker block
We have this for really gap inside this breaker block right we have an auto block inside this breaker block right
So wouldn't it be wise
To take a trade from the breaker breaker instead of waiting for price to come here because on the one minute
especially price is very very like intense okay it's very strong so it may not
hit your friendly gap on one minute so utilize the breaker look at the
look at these things okay if you take your entry from a breaker it just stop
gonna be the same almost the same if you took your entry from this friendly gap
or this autoblock if yes go for it if you don't want to miss your trade go for
the closest for a valley gap, right? This could be this, but all this put your
stop here. And I think guys, that is it for this lecture. I want you guys to
back test. I try my best to show you the different variations, right? In each
example, so you can better understand this whole system. Okay, we had this, we
didn't have consolidation here, but then look at this. We'll see the difference
between here and here.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
But here, but do we have?
We have nothing price.
And consecutive green candles, pull back, green candles,
pull back, green candles, pull back.
So yeah, I think guys, that is it.
I'm gonna do one or two more lectures about,
let's say how to pause your profile
and a one bonus video, all right?
And then the course update will end.
If we have understood everything that I've taught
Right now, congratulations, you are about to become an independent trader.
Okay?
When you have like the bias, you can use my every single strategy,
even the basics ones, right?
By using like external and internal.
For the example, I showed you internal and external,
that can work as well, but you need to know the auto flow.
If you have the correct auto flow, that is absolutely beautiful.
Alright, I'm gonna end the video here.
See you guys in the next one.